foreign
[Music]
against a 1744
and obviously as is our custom we play
E4
we'll dedicate this to chigoran for
those watching on YouTube I um just
spent a while going in a little chess
history tangent and talking about
Mikhail chiguran one of the top players
of the 19th century world champion
Contender one of the strongest tactical
players of his day okay we're facing the
Sicilian once again
we play the allopin and the Elephant by
the way himself was
probably top 20 in the world uh not
close to a world champion but also lived
in the same time I think as shigorn and
steinitson was a contemporary and you
know contributed tremendously to opening
theory he was mostly an opening
theoretician I think from Lithuania
originally but also a strong player okay
so Knight C6 is one of the most common
responses to the elephant but it is
already believe it or not a serious
inaccuracy I wouldn't go so far as to
call it a mistake if black follows up
correctly then black can essentially
turn this into a viable system but if
black makes one more inaccuracy things
can actually get disastrously bad within
five six moves now our response to
Knight C6 is obvious why do we play C3
well we play that to prepare D4 Knight
C6 doesn't actually prevent D4 we have
enough Defenders on that square so we
start by grabbing control of the center
and in short the reason that the Knight
on C6 is often misplaced in these lines
is is actually quite simple first of all
we recapture it with a pawn we're
essentially threatening to push the
spawn down to D5
and without the support of a pawn shell
this is why as I've explained before
it's a bad idea to bring your pieces out
without moving your pawns because then
your pawns start tossing those pieces
around and the pieces just don't have
any footholds in the center and
ultimately could even get trapped or
driven back to their initial squares
which could be a disaster given the
extent of our central control
so for instance after D5 I know it's
black to move but just for the sake of
illustration d595 right we follow up
with F4 and there you kind of see that
the Knight on E5 has to move all the way
back to G6
and it's going to be tremendously hard
for black and those resulting positions
to get the other pieces out a big
mistake here would be to play Knight F6
this would actually throw oil onto the
fire because in that line after D5 95 F4
Knight G6
we actually play E5 and the only square
that the Knight on F6 will have is to go
back to G8 because both G4 and H5 are
covered by White's Queen good example of
quote unquote violating opening
principles and moving only your pawns
but here it's obviously Justified
because we're tossing Black's pieces
around we're playing with tempo
so already a very dangerous situation
for black I had an eight move game that
I played when I was 1800 that I'll show
quickly after this game in that game my
opponent played E6 in this position
the best move theoretically is D5 black
needs to counter strike in the center
but after D5 we get a very very
theoretical continuation in which black
and I once again lose and flame out in
just a couple of moves
so according to the engine D5 is
strongest here but black needs to know
exactly what to do in the resulting
position to avoid getting you know
smashed in the center and driven out of
the gym
yeah after D5 we take
so in short we either play our own Pawn
to D5
grabbing more control of the center and
chasing the Knight away
the second approach is just to develop
our pieces Knight C3 and Knight F3 which
uh is always a decent alternative
and if black plays D5
then we will take on D5 and a common
Instinct for players is of course to
meet D5 with E5 but who can explain
positionally and you know again if
you're watching on YouTube something you
can figure out why all our opponent is
thinking okay D5 on the board very nice
why is E5 not accurate here because you
might especially if you play the
advanced French you might say well this
is just like an advanced French but
there is a key difference
in the French the black Pond is already
on E6 so black has what we call the
French Bishop the light squared Bishop
which always experiences problems after
E5 here black gets essentially a very
very good French or a good Karo Khan
getting the bishop out to F5 and only
then locking up the center with E6 so
you don't want to get into a French
where you've let the light squared
Bishop out that's an inferior version
it's not losing for white or anything
like that but it doesn't pose serious
problems so long story short we take on
D5 and we transpose into a line that
could also be reached with a different
move order in fact it normally is
reached with the move order D5 here move
2 trade D4 trade and Knight C6 so you
can follow in your head that line and
you will see that the same position is
reached a very common mistake for
inexperienced players to play Knight C3
right the instinct to attack the queen
unfortunately this is not a scandi and
you have to notice that the D4 Pawn is
hanging it's got two attackers on it and
only one Defender so we first and
foremost need to protect that pawn while
developing our other night Knight F3
and if you stumble into this opening
without theoretical knowledge this
should actually look very scary
especially if black puts the bishop on
G4 because it may seem that we have
absolutely no chance of keeping the pawn
on D4 alive and what's interesting is
that after Bishop G4 we actually
sacrificed that pawn but we do it
strategically and develop a massive
initiative I'll show you some really
really cool resulting lines and maybe
we'll even get them on the board
so after Bishop G4 Knight C3 is the move
trying to force the queen out of the
center
and conceptually the one big thing to
know here is that if the queen is driven
back from D5 we can ourselves then
Advance the pawn to D5 and that can lead
immediately to catastrophic consequences
because black is so underdeveloped on
the king side that if we're able to push
our Pawn to D5 and drive the Knight back
there is a check on B5 there's a queen
check on A4 and that could all be
totally deadly if black is not very
cautious yeah and this is already an iqp
structure iqp a common abbreviation for
isolated Queen Pawn isolated meaning
that there are no neighboring Pawns
um no C Pawn no e-pawn both of those
pawns have been traded or transformed
the C Pawn still exists it's just now
the d-pawn right this originally was the
pawn that sat on C3
yeah so black has like three major
continuations here that are considered
legitimate according to Theory Bishop G4
is very popular but to my knowledge a
bad move objectively and if white
responds accurately black already gets
in serious trouble but you basically
have to know exactly what to do here
with white
as far as I know the objectively best
continuation the one that reduces the
damage is actually the very modest move
E6 which is not a move a lot of people
want to play because it closes down the
bishop but the move E6 lends another
support to the D5 Square so that after
we bring our Knight out and the queen
moves back the move D5 doesn't come with
as much effect black can just take it
okay Bishop G4 played and I love that
we're getting this because this is a
super important line and if you're an
alopin player you're gonna get this a
lot in online play and you're gonna get
this in over the board play as well so
again I like to approach this from the
perspective of someone who hasn't seen
this position before because that gives
you insight into what your intuition is
likely to be and that gives you a better
chance to remember
counter-intuitive moves right when you
know what the intuitive move is and you
know that that it's wrong you can make a
memory marker in that regard so to me
there's a pin on the night and there's
an instinct I think for a lot of people
to play Bishop E2
especially because if black takes on F3
and takes on D4 he loses the queen
because Bishop takes c6's check
eliminating the defender I'll show all
of this on the board after the game the
issue with Bishop E2 isn't that it's
wrong tactically it's that it's slow and
it allows black to bring the pawn out to
E6
and prepare himself for the uh
inevitable Knight C3 so we need to cut
out the middleman here and we need to go
directly for the queen while black still
has not gone E6 we need to play Knight
C3 straight away
now if you look carefully at this move
it may seem that black has a very
compelling response and as a hint this
response does not involve moving the
queen if black moves the queen he's
busted and we already know what to do
we're going to push D5 essentially
automatically and black and lose there
in like another three moves there is
this weird move Bishop takes Knight
right
and it leads to a bunch of chaos if we
take the queen then black takes Our
Queen and if we recapture the bishop
with our King then not only have we lost
our castling rights but that Knight on
D5
can be targeted with long castles the
Knight is hanging the pawn on D4 is
surely going to be lost there and that
doesn't seem appetizing in the least
now you could say but wait a second
after Bishop takes F3 Knight takes Queen
Bishop takes Queen we don't have to
recapture the bishop we can give a fork
on C7 but that is also problematic
because if you extend the line King d8
Knight takes A8 you don't even need to
calculate any further to understand that
that position is not all roses for white
because the Knight on A8 isn't really
getting out and if black is able to
track that Knight down and win it then
black will have two pieces for The Rook
which given the fact that the Rooks are
still you know on their initial spots is
not a Rosy option for white so in
response to Bishop takes F3 this is one
of the lines you have to memorize you
simply have to memorize it you also have
to understand it but if you want to be a
good elephant player this is one of the
lines you should start with and I will
uh it's a shame that our opponent didn't
take on F3 but that's okay it remains
behind the scenes and it will await us
in our post game analysis this is just
as important to know how to refute Queen
to A5
okay so as already indicated our
Instinct here and we just need to double
check that this move is still good but I
still think it is is to play D5
right why why the urgency to push the
pawn because if we allow black to play
E6 then D5 loses a lot of its a lot a
lot of its effect because it just allows
black to trade on D5 and we are unable
to kick the Knight out of C6 why is it
important to kick the Knight out of C6
well first of all because it is nowhere
good to go and second of all because
once the Knight moves away from C6 we
have an incredibly nasty check on B5
that could actually Force the king to
move to d8 and that's a complete
disaster especially with the King side
entirely undeveloped so definitely we go
D5 here and we do that without a second
thought I think black and probably worm
his way out of this and avoid an
immediate disaster with some computer
play but practically speaking Black's
position is already borderline lost and
these are bold words but hopefully I can
back that up with the course of the game
yeah so some of you are rightly noticing
that black does not have to move the
night away
and black can make this very sneaky move
long castle with the idea of pinning the
d-pawn to the queen and D takes C6 would
be very unwise because we lose the queen
with check
but after one Castle
it's important to note two things the
first is that the black king on C8 is
incredibly vulnerable not because
castling long is inherently dangerous
although it is but because the C file is
open and not only is it open it's very
easy for us to get a rook to see one and
everybody should understand why getting
a rook to C1 would be so dangerous to
Black right The Rook has a direct line
of fire to the king and the King might
simply not make it all the way into the
corner and even if it does there are
other Horrors that await the King on A8
I'll show you a good illustration of
this after the game one of my earliest
alapan wins and sort of Fondest Memories
a game from the the under 10 world youth
in 2005 against a player who is now a
very strong GM himself
so Castle King's uh Queen side is is not
scary and neither is Rook to d8 Rook to
d8 temporarily defends the Knight but we
could very easily reinforce renew the
threat of D take C6 we can do that in
many different ways we can simply move
the queen out of the pin we can go Queen
B3 we can also block the pin with a move
like Bishop D2 which is also very
productive because it sets up our own
x-ray against the queen
so bad news here for black and I think
our opponent recognizes it takes on F3
okay
so here let's try to play as precisely
as possible let's try to go for the kill
quickly without allowing any additional
options so
again the intuitive response is Queen
takes F3 unless there is a good reason
you don't want to damage your kingside
Pawn structure not that we're afraid to
get checkmated but you know if Queen
takes F3 is good then we should play it
now does Queen takes F3 have any
downsides well as I see it it has only
one sort of downside that we need to
reckon with which is that Queen takes F3
allows the Knight to jump into the
center with Tempo with either Knight D4
or Knight E5 and Knight D4 might seem
like the scarier move to you because the
Knight also threatens to travel onward
to C2 but let's look concretely Queen
takes F3 Knight D4 is not actually
dangerous at all because the queen can
centralize to E4 preventing Knight C2
because it covers the score and
simultaneously attacking the Knight
the Knight actually doesn't have
anywhere to go because it's completely
restricted by The Pawn on D5 Queen takes
F3 Knight E5 might actually be a more
resilient move for black but similarly
it's not dangerous it hits Our Queen yes
but we could move our Queen up to F5 or
even play the same move Queen E4
so the upside of playing GF here and
spoiler alert I think either move is
possible and I'm actually not sure which
one is better
GF is cool because after the Knight
moves the Knight has nowhere to go with
Tempo so after the night moves let's say
to the same E5 Square we could bring our
Bishop out with check and virtually
Force the king to move into the center
which is a total disaster or if the
Knight would have to block similarly
looks very very ugly so I like GTX F3 I
like Queen takes F3 Queen takes F3 is
the more positionally sound move the
move that you would play if you wanted
to to play with an abundance of caution
I'm actually not sure I'll think about
this for like a couple moments
GF 95
we could also go Queen B3 there
attacking B7
both options look incredibly juicy this
is a very good problem to have but I do
have a gut feeling
I have a gut feeling and I can't fully
explain it my gut feeling is that Queen
takes F3 is better
and and it's just it's just an intuitive
sense and there are there is like one
consideration that justifies that which
I'll talk about after the game but I
don't want to delve too deeply into it
okay so 95 is the instant response by
our opponent and now okay two options
that I like Queen E4 and queen to F5
both moves hit the Knight and both moves
bring the queen to a more active spot
now Queen F5 I think I like more for one
main reason after Queen to E4 the Knight
let's say drops back to D7 and that
Queen on e4 is gonna be vulnerable to
Knight G to F6 and the way that we screw
this up with white is we allow black to
get his entire King side out quickly and
if that happens and black is able to
Castle kingside which sounds incredibly
distant but it's not actually that many
moves away we can't fall asleep here
because how many moves does black need
one two three and on the fourth block is
already ready to castle that's not
forever
so we don't want to give black Tempo
moves for no reason Bishop B5 would be a
very instructive mistake because if
Queen takes B5
Desperado Knight takes B5 Knight takes
F3 and importantly that's a check right
we can't go Knight C7 there because our
King is in check we have to recapture
the Knight and the worst thing we could
do here is allow a queen trade
also very good is to play Queen G3
lovely move as well Queen G3 uh is is
fantastic too because it keeps the queen
out of the weeds and it keeps it out of
the way of White's pieces and also out
of the way of Black's pieces right the
queen on G3 can basically not be
attacked at all
so let me think about this again for
just a second Queen G3 versus queen F5
is what I'm trying to decide between and
there's some calculation to do there
we have five there there there's a cool
idea there that I'm wrestling with not
sure how strong it is
not strong not
so there there there
D6 gosh that looks very juicy as well
hmm
yeah in a classical game I'd probably go
Queen G3
but I'm agonizing I really want to play
this accurately
because I want to finish the game before
move 20 if possible
hmm
okay
let's adhere to a rule that I have
shared
before in previous speed runs which
originally comes from Yasser Sarah one
yeah yes
and Yasser introduced this to me like
many years ago when he talked about
using the queen as a supporting actress
that's like the terminology that he used
and I have a chess.com article based on
that and the idea is simple right when
we think of how our Queen should
participate in an attack we often think
that the queen should be on the front
lines right it should be right in your
opponent's Grill but the queen is a lot
it's the ultimate long-range piece so
oftentimes it might be a bit
counter-intuitive but keeping the queen
in the shadows directing to the attack
from a distance can often be a lot more
effective simply because the queen is
such a valuable piece that you want to
keep your main War general you know
behind safe Lions to avoid a situation
where the queen starts stumbling around
and allowing dempo moves well Queen G3
to that end seems like a perfect spot
for the queen because it's doing a lot
of stuff stacking the Knight is
pressuring G7 it's potentially can
infiltrate to C7 if the black queen
moves obviously
um it's also discouraging black from
castling Queen side
but it's essentially as I said earlier
unattackable
whereas on F5 the queen may seem to be
doing more but it is very much
attackable right it might walk into G6
and again I don't want to give like any
developmental Tempo moves
so hopefully the general logic makes
sense there are some specific lines I
looked at there
um which I'll which I'll share afterward
Knight D7
okay so it would be very very nice if we
could play Knight to B5 because Knight
C7 would be very hard to stop
unfortunately that's illegal and in
general this pin is annoying me the
queen on A5 is Black's only good piece
and it I think is sensible to take the
sting out of it
so as as tempted as some people may be
by Bishop B5 which I know is on the tip
of some people's tongue great move by
the way nothing wrong with it but Bishop
B5 black develops the Knight to F6 and
just the pin against the Knight alone
isn't going to win us the game it's hard
to pressure that D7 Knight another time
so let's make a more modest looking move
Bishop to D2 but I think this really
allows us to fulfill the potential of
our pieces it threatens Knight B5 that's
the direct threat attacking the queen
discovered attack and the Knight C7 is
Unstoppable so black already has to do
something against that threat probably
move the queen back which gives us
another Tempo that we can use either to
play Bishop E5 or maybe to still play
Knight B5 which is still very dangerous
even if it doesn't attack the queen
depending on what white does black does
will will decide on a subsequent course
of action now I'm positive if you're
following the game with an engine that
I'm not playing perfectly I have no
doubt about that and it's hard to play
perfectly in a position where you've got
like five or six tempting options on
each move
you shouldn't expect yourself to play
perfectly you should expect yourself to
make reasonable moves which almost
always will lead to a positive
conclusion even if you don't play
perfectly this was a genius move by our
opponent that I completely missed this
is a incredible idea that our opponent
just uncovered and the idea is to meet
Knight B5 with Queen takes Bishop check
King takes Queen and 94 check picks up
the White Queen
and as a result attacks The Rook on H1
which will force us to recapture on G3
and again we are trying to avoid the end
game like a plague so this is the
importance of double checking that your
opponent's move doesn't in fact prevent
your main idea right at this level 1700
plus most of the time people are gonna
see one move threats so your instincts
should always be to double check now
let's not panic right you see that it's
easy to panic let's root out the source
of the problem the source of the problem
is this e-force Square so can we defend
that square but not a move like F3 which
doesn't do anything else can we develop
a piece and protect that square I like
the simple move Bishop D3 yeah it gets
the bishop out
and it reinforces the threat of Knight
B5
and in general the way that we're
playing is such that we're preparing for
the worst case scenario right you
shouldn't sacrifice pieces without need
you shouldn't do crazy stuff unless you
need to and the way we're playing like
even if the worst case scenario comes to
pass and black finds some way to Castle
kingside guess what it's really not the
end of the world we still have the
bishop pair we still have a strong Pawn
in the center that we'll be able to
defend and black still has problems with
coordinating other pieces
so we're trying to win the game quickly
but we're also making moves that are
independently good and those are the
types of moves you should strive for to
avoid
you know crashing and burning in a
winning position sometimes you you have
to go for the sack and sometimes you
have to go for the the risky
continuation but here we've got the
luxury of making these types of moves
they're not always the you know gonna
win you the beauty prize but they're
gonna win you a lot of games
yeah black intake D5 but I don't care
about that we're just gonna Castle we're
just gonna keep developing and we're
gonna eat the king alive eventually once
The Rook comes into the open file once
The Rook comes to E1
that King on E8 is just going to be
complete and utter toast
also what I like is that Knight takes D5
opens up the D file
and you could say well how does that
matter at all
well it doesn't on the next move but it
will in three moves because after we
Castle we could bring the a rook over to
D1 what's on the D file well that Knight
on D7 that we actually started with that
was our initial concept that night later
on could be just victimized massacred
with a move like Bishop B5 and combined
with the Rook on D1 you could kind of
Envision a scenario where the pressure
against the Knight becomes instantly
unbearable
foreign
now another thing that I kind of keep
repeating like a broken record is that
when you play in this way and you put
pressure
from the very first moves even if object
even if a computer could survive for
another 50 moves and turn the game
around notice what's happening he's
taking loads of time on every move and
almost certainly a blunder is going to
come to to expedite the process in the
next couple of moves I think we are
winning objectively but likely our
opponent's going to help us out just
because the pressure is so unbearable
what should black do here I think black
is toast Queen B6
so
patience is the order of the day and I
think I think Knight B5 is very very
tempting
that was our initial idea but it no
longer comes with Tempo it no longer
attacks the queen and so Knight B5 black
and meat perhaps with Knight takes D5
which I don't really see the need to
allow
so what is a good patient simple move
that we could play relatively fast keeps
all of our advantages and just prepares
you know major major problems on the
evening yeah just castle castle King
side I think some of you might be
wondering if we can Castle queenside but
again no need no need to be fancy that
King on C1
because of the semi-open C file two can
play at that game why allow black
counter-plan activity along the C file
Castle kingside is uh you know much more
prudent here
talk that King away
and now the e-file is a direct line of
access against the black king and we
have the Machinery to exploit it I'm
expecting G6
and there we will have to be very
accurate because black will be only two
moves away from castling but I think
that gives us just enough time to
generate threats before the king is able
to escape
no long castle for white is fine the
White's not going to get checkmated
there it's just annoying
A6 okay
the problem is our opponent is trying to
cover things with a Band-Aid but like
the whole you know the whole world is
exploding here for black you know he
shot down one balloon but there's others
so what do we do now now that we can't
go in ip5 we can try to play like tall
we can try to play like tall and go D6
and it's it's a tempting move because if
you can open the E file that looks like
absolute death to the black king the
issue is that after D6 black can meet
that with E6 a move that's very commonly
overlooked right actually pushing the
pawn past your Pawn
and what might end up happening is that
we actually lose the D6 pawn and we
still don't get to open the e-file again
we need to play it very simple here the
simple moves are by far the strongest in
these types of overwhelming positions
you just need to accumulate and
accumulate and eventually you need to
sense the moment when you know the sort
of slow moves allow you to find some
sort of concrete combination but right
now we still have low hanging fruit that
we can pick off and Rook fe1 is just
such a you know an example just putting
the Rook on the same file as our as the
enemy King and preparing to launch some
Shenanigans against the E7 Pawn now by
the way D6 is more tempting but still D6
we should not rush because of E6
something to really take away from this
game right a very common mistake D6 E6
and suddenly we've actually improved
Black's Pawn shell
okay Queen takes B2 is obviously
possible but
you know pinching a dinosaur is how you
should think of it we really could not
care less about a corner Pawn
yeah that attacks the bishop but these
are just one move threats that can be
easily addressed we probably have some
tactical win against Queen takes B2
maybe Queen C7 is winning something like
that but we wouldn't even have to do
that we'll talk after the game about it
okay
so this is where we really need to
hunker down because we have two moves we
have three minutes on the clock so I'll
have to speed up and we need to find
some way to prevent Bishop G7 and
Castle's kingside preferably without
going crazy so let me think about this
for a minute
because I don't I don't see it yet but
I'm sure it'll it'll occur to us
I have one idea I have sort of a backup
option
I have a backup option
but I want to find something really
pretty
okay
man I have a cool idea but it doesn't
quite do the trick
okay we could double on the E file but
black will gladly give up the E7 Pawn in
order to castle that's not you know
that's that's not how our Rome was built
hmm
there's a line that almost results in
mate but again keyword being almost
94 Knight takes C4
rookie for Bishop B7 I'm genuinely
calculating by the way I'm not trying to
be you know pretend that
I'm looking and I've already found it I
haven't found it yet
I think we're gonna go for the backup
option
and the backup option might be the best
move in the position so let me play the
move just because of the time and again
if you're sort of feeling lost we'll
talk after the game more more deeply
Bishop to E3 hit the queen
counter-intuitive in its appearance
because we blocked the e-file but
remember when you block a file with your
own piece right you are in control of
your own pieces this is a Frankfurt
airport Type move
I'm trying to force the queen onto a
worse spot
in the event of Queen takes B2 we're
gonna put the bishop on D4 this is
ultimately
likely the final destination for the
bishop why D4 well because it's on the
long diagonal it's pressuring the Knight
and it's really adding strain uh to the
position to Black's position
but it really depends on where the queen
goes the queen doesn't have a lot of
squares actually surprisingly it does
not Queen D6 maybe but then we can even
play Bishop F4
Queen back to d8 the king is fully boxed
in Knight H5 our opponent trying to be
fancy but ultimately I think this just
loses the game on the spot and again and
again I think this is a theme of this
game
that's going to ultimately be a big
takeaway
when you're trying to win games
it's easy to walk into the impression
that every attack is supposed to be
beautiful and every attack is culminated
with a sacrifice and we probably could
do that if we wanted to but we're
playing the speedrun to win games
efficiently and for me to show how to
win games efficiently and there's a very
efficient win here first thing you have
to calculate when both Queens are
hanging there's a checklist first item
on the checklist can we move our Queen
away with check
thereby winning the queen no right well
we can play Queen B8 but that doesn't
help second thing can we Desperado Our
Queen can we give our Queen up for
something and then take our opponent
screen no we can take the pawn but that
makes no sense our opponent just
recaptures and ultimately we just lose a
piece third thing what happens if we
actually take our opponent's Queen and
then try to move that piece away with
Tempo this is what we have Bishop takes
B6 as many of you are pointing out after
Knight takes G3 if we take the Knight
then black is chilling but can we move
the bishop away with tempo
essentially resulting in a double attack
and I'm kind of guiding you toward the
right move Bishop D4 is very simple and
you know this is the kind of move that
you find intuitively with enough
tactical practice
boring Bland but utterly and completely
winning because we're gonna win at least
a minor piece or maybe even a rook
and that's it we take on G3 and the
greatest thing is that if black moves
The Rook then black loses the ability to
Castle kingside and it's not like just
because the Queens are off the board our
attack dissipates I mean we have a
million pieces left and I can almost
guarantee you that unless our opponent
resigns which is likely the game is
probably going to end in some sort of
checkmate
likely along the e-file
we've reached our final destination
which is D4 kind of fitting
yeah so our opponent does decide I see
what what he's trying to do I think F6
is the idea trying to trap the bishop
ingenious
and under different circumstances I
think this would be the way to go but
here I think we can use tactics
essentially to
keep the bishop alive for long enough
until we find a way to extricate it
so I love people's instincts here right
there is a move that we have patiently
refrained from because it's been
ineffective until now but now I think is
the time for that move and the the
general reason why is that Black's Pawn
structure is now the weakest it has been
for the whole game but now I think it's
time to really step on the gas pedal but
there's a more specific reason this move
is strong and and I'm talking here about
the move D6
so there's a couple of additional
benefits to this move and one of them is
that we get a monster Square for one of
our pieces that square is good in and of
itself but that square also allows us to
win back uh actually win the Knight on
H5
everybody should be aware of the move G4
here G4 is very strong were it not for
Knight to F4 so wouldn't it be nice if
we could cover the F4 Square what could
we do it with well we could do it with
the Knight and that's why we pushed the
Deep on carving out a Central Square
the bishop can take D6 which is an
annoying move because it covers C7 but
now we play G4 and the Knight is trapped
the Knight is trapped Knight F4 Knight
takes F4 and the B Pawn is pinned so
black should move the king out of the
way
and yes black will win the bishop on h8
but we win in return the Knight and we
are up a full rook in the resulting
position which is an easy technical win
so
we couldn't move the bishop out on its
own because G7 was covered but what we
could do is use our other active pieces
to win the Knight on H5 which is
ironically like the piece that's
restricting the bishop
you have seven good job by our opponent
by the way to find a couple of good
resources but it's not going to help
so let's get down to business here
things that I notice we could take G6 it
really doesn't matter I mean I'm not
worried about GH that's just a random
Corner pawn and actually that further
weakens the light squares
so the the Russian Schoolboy move here
would be to identify these two minor
pieces the bishop and the Knight what
can we say about them well first of all
they're on the same file second of all
they're undefended thirdly you should
notice the black's King on F7 is
tremendously vulnerable
so a nice move here a Sleek move would
actually be to First bring the Rook into
D1 a lot of you would be tempted by
Bishop C4 which might even be the best
move but I like to play in this kind of
nifty classy way we bring the Rook into
the game and we are setting up all sorts
of shenanigans against these two minor
pieces
how are we going to put them into effect
well we're going to bring the bishop out
of the way
and simultaneously that's going to
create threats against the black king so
where can we go
well actually I really like the look of
H6 here
setting up a potential mating net why H6
well that pawn is like a free play in
American football where like we don't
care if we lose it so we might as well
use it while it's still alive and it
might actually uh end the game still
alive what are we depriving the black
king of well the G7 score we're actually
entombing the black king in the center
and not allowing it as an escape hatch
to H6 now it's finally time for the move
that perhaps you wanted to play earlier
and that's Bishop C4 setting up the
threat of a discovered check against the
black king
and now we end the game with what very
very simple tactic it's not the bishop
that we end up winning it's actually not
even the night well it might be the
night it's The Rook which is also
undefended that's why we put the Rook
under one to set up this tactic Knight
takes F6 I hope my internet doesn't go
out that would be sad
Knight takes F6 and the game is over
and what's hilarious is that if King E7
is played which it is not only is the H6
Pawn going to be alive for the rest of
the game but it's going to win the game
for us and the simplest way to play you
have 10 seconds you're starting to panic
get the pieces off the board right trade
everything that'll greatly simplify your
task takes takes and now
we're looking at these two pawns when
you have a far Advanced Pawn in the end
game it can be a great weakness in the
middle game but a great asset in the end
game because that pawn is a future Queen
Bishop G8 is a slam dunk move winning H7
then we step away with our Bishop
promote the pawn and win the game
yeah
that's it
I think resignation is uh
imminent and our opponent resigns GG 29
moves but a lot happened in those 29
moves
okay let's have a look
1750 is what we end up with
yeah definitely I could go down the
theoretical Rabbit Hole here
but I will give you the sort of General
summary without bugging ourselves down
to uh too much into the weeds because
again we'll have plenty of time to talk
more about the theory so Knight C6
and D4 and the first branching off point
is is here after the trade so our
opponent played the main move which is
D5 very common at like a 12 1300 level
is the move E6 and as a little bit of
inspiration I want to start by showing
you my my like one of my shortest games
shortest tournament in this classical
game
and against a 1757 I was rated 1873 13
moves I exaggerated slightly but but
still maybe it was a very one-sided game
that illustrates that
the danger of playing this line with
black and the power of White's
well-developed pieces
so this was in Vegas a tournament that I
played many many years in a row
my opponent was Jeff Schroeder I gave
this game in my um
method Series so some of you will
probably be familiar with it
and
as you can see we got this position now
you should take my next moves with a
grain of salt because the best move in
this position according to the engine
the move that I'll talk more about is
the immediate D5 just immediately
striking at the center instead I I took
a slower approach I played Knight F3
which is fine it keeps an advantage but
I try to give you the objectively best
options Knight F6 by my opponent Knight
C3 and here believe it or not a decisive
Mistake by black
the only way to essentially stay alive
was to play well either Bishop before or
D5
here I was planning E5 and this is a
great version of an of an advanced
French because now the bishop is locked
on C8 and in the advanced French you're
not supposed to give the White Knight
the C3 developing Square so white is
much better here but the game would have
continued Bishop B Simon is one of those
automatic developing moves which shows
in sort of an unfamiliarity with with
White's main idea here
and before my opponent knew it he's
losing dead lost in two more moves
so what does white do
based on what you already know about
this position
yeah very good D5 D5
this is much stronger than E5 which
yields the D5 square and black is able
to Halt the progress of White's pawns D5
is much stronger my opponent trades
doesn't change anything and D6 simply
ends the game if the bishop drops back
there's Queen E2 check and the game is
over black has to make the pathetic
Bishop E7 and the rest you can figure
out on your own my opponent tried one
trick takes a knight C2 check but I
could not care less about that Rook
because the bishop comes out pre-move
rookie one and that's it Black's King is
is utterly 94 was tried but rookie one
is my response not even taking the
Knight like preparing to take over the
rooken it's mate like in a thousand
different ways here and he resigned it
almost looks like black barely made any
moves in this game and yet that's just
what happens when you don't develop
accurately and you don't grab the center
with your Pawns
so that was like a nice inspiring game
um that inspired me to continue playing
the albumin
in terms of
actual opening Theory and let me confirm
this with stockfish 15 but I'm pretty
sure that this still stands
the best move here Knight F3 is second
best but D5 is even stronger and it's
it's a similar idea to the game not not
quite as clear-cut so if black takes it
we take back
and the Knight essentially is nowhere
good to go if black plays Knight to E5
then now we finally develop our pieces
we just go Knight C3 and there's a
million ways for black to lose the game
quickly if Knight F6 we actually push D6
here
it's very scary looking move because you
might be afraid to lose your D6 spawn
but if black tries to pick it off with
his Queen the Knight comes in just in
time and Knight C7 is a devastating
threat
black has to move the king out of the
way of the fork King d8 now we bring our
Bishop into the game attacking the queen
and the line that I looked at is Queen
A5 Chuck Bishop drops back
and after the queen moves back only
square is B6
uh incredibly strong here is ridiculous
computer move lovely computer move A3
this is one of those freaking moves that
shows you who's boss
what the heck is the idea well who can
figure it out
what is the idea of this move the idea
is actually twofold which is kind of
cool first of all we need to talk about
Bishop takes D6 second of all and we'll
start with this we should talk about A6
what's the idea of A3
yeah very good we returned to E3
and after Queen A5 we now have the move
before the queen is simply trapped black
has to give it away and if the queen
goes the other way then it's attacked by
The Rook it cannot catch a break check
and this is uh just totally totally
crushing
black plays Bishop takes D6 the second
idea of A3 comes into play
here we take
and it may seem like Bishop A5 check
wins the queen but not just yet black
has King E7 and now we drop back to B4
so the square itself the fact that it's
protected now is important we either put
the bishop or the pawn on B4 and in both
cases win Black's Queen and you're
joking giant Knight really cool idea I
love these Quiet Moves but what I love
about them is that you can understand
exactly why they're played after the
lines are displayed but it's hard to
figure it out if if you don't know this
idea to begin with A3 is is just amazing
and it's the best move it's not you know
no no dispute about that
so the top engine move is actually
Bishop check
here trying to develop a Tempo we cover
with the Knight
and here again Knight E5 is likely
and we just bring the other night out to
F3
trying to get rid of getting rid of
Black's only active piece D6 drops uh
the bishop this is a common allopin idea
so remember it
if black takes it then we take with the
queen and we just have a tremendous
position here we've got this Monster
Pawn on D5
and we've got you know fantastic
development for our pieces for instance
Bishop D3 castles castles D6 it looks
like black is sort of out of the woods
but he's not I mean the pin against the
Knight is deadly the Bishops aiming at
H7 the Queen's pressuring the Knight
black still hasn't completed their
development and this is just a complete
and total disaster it's around plus two
according to the engine that's if black
plays perfectly
so you can dig around here on your own
suffice it to say the D5 the position is
pretty easy to play as long as you know
to push the pawn to D6 with the Knight
having already come out to C3
all right so that's the rundown of E6 at
a lower level you often see the move
Knight to F6 and as I hinted at uh
during the game here again you go D5 and
a great illustration of why you have to
push Pawns in the opening is this line
where white plays out four
forcing the Knight back another pawn
move forces the other Knight back and
just look at how disastrous this
position is black literally cannot move
and there's a really lovely line after
D6 black tries to establish some sort of
presence in the end game another
ridiculous cracked out computer idea
watch this E6
now this just looks like a flat out
blunder F takes E6 D6 Bishop E6 and you
might say oh there's a fork but no F5 is
unprotected that's not the idea the idea
is to follow up with H4
threatening H5
no problem the Knight will move except
it can't move it has nowhere to go after
H5 and if black halts the progress of
the pawn then the Knight is unprotected
which means we could bring the bishop
out developing with tempo if black
defends with the King then we have a
fork if black goes to Bishop F7 then
suddenly the bishop misdirects to B5 and
we win the queen
so just the energy in White's position
here is is amazing
so another line torns or shreds
um
and last thing I'll point out is is the
move D6 also very common at sort of the
you know beginner to intermediate level
and again you go D5 and here it's it's a
little bit less clear-cut after F4 but
still the black's position is horrendous
absolutely horrendous and the one thing
you should remember is that if black
tries to fianchetto the bishop with G6
you can actually prevent this and who
can spot a move that again violates the
general opening principle but makes
perfect sense now that you're aware of
how dangerous the progress of the epon
can be
yeah Queen D4 is automatic either
forcing F6 or in the event of Knight f65
losing the game on the spot
uh for Black Knight h5e6 and
then always there's a check at the end
because D7 is covered
black loses everything here not just a
piece but also the rook in the corner
so yeah
this is why Knight C6 is not a good move
our opponent plays D5 trade and Knight
F3 now there are many many lines here
that I could talk I could talk about
this for an hour all I will mention here
is the bishop takes F3 line which I'll
show in a moment this is sort of the
main takeaway because here it's
important to recognize that if you turn
on the engine it will give you a
misleading assessment you need to keep
the engine on at a high depth to figure
out the best continuation so here it's
important to listen carefully
the only other move here that occurs
frequently is E5
white responds with Knight C3 and black
pins the Knight with Bishop to B4 this
is nothing to be afraid of we just go
Bishop D2 ending the pin renewing the
threat against the queen and essentially
forcing the trade and getting the bishop
pair right this is just a better
position for white because the bishop
aims at G7 and if black plays E4 then we
dive forward to E5 and this is
considered to be slightly better for
white there is nothing insane here white
is slightly better because of the bishop
pair and you know the pawn and E4 can be
weak I think Knight E7 is the main line
then the queen delivers a check and
actually the new recommendation in the
chess level course I think is Queen to
B4 here aiming at the Knight and
preventing black from castling short you
can keep analyzing this on your own uh
you can find this in the in the
chessable course that recently came out
on the alopin uh but white species are
coming out at a furious tempo
so E5 is not you know a big problem but
a common line
and finally the last part of our opening
overview before we get to the game is
Bishop takes F3 which you will
definitely meet if you play the albumin
often so here the best move is to
recapture with the pawn
now this looks like a flat out blunder
because well that's the whole point of
Black's move black takes D4 and now you
do something absolutely crazy this is
impossible to find if you aren't aware
of it beforehand
you trade Queens
looks like total self-sabotage
and now not only do you not defend C2
you play this move Knight to B5
yeah very good I see a couple of you are
familiar with this line not entirely I
know this is pretty well known by this
point and I can check if there are any
games
there are a lot of games yeah there's
over 100 games here so this is a
well-known line and it's been well known
ever since 1959 believe it or not it was
first played so it's it's not exactly a
novelty and this is just incredibly
problematic for black
so what's going on here
well first thing
we should notice is that Knight C2 check
allows the white to carry out his main
idea King D1
Knight takes A1
obviously we counter Fork The Rook on
A8 and you might say and this is
actually the most popular continuation
among humans Knight takes a eight and
now most people here with black play a
move like E6 and you might say well
Black's gonna go around and win white
snide and White's probably gonna win
black snide and White's just gonna be
down upon but it's not that simple
because you can use your Bishops to
prevent Black's King from making it to
B8 you give one check and after King CA
very important move Bishop out to F4
preventing King B8 and opening up an
Escape Route for the Knight although you
don't need to go Knight C7 you're
already winning here
a 2390 walked into this with black in
2007 he played G5 trying to deflect the
bishop obviously white stays on the
diagonal Bishop G3
this is a novelty by the way for some
reason white played Bishop takes G5 in
the game but Bishop G3 is ending Bishop
G7
King moves out of the way attacking the
Knight if the Knight moves the Knight is
pinned in one
and if black comes to the rescue then
the winning line is Rogue B1 attacking
the bishop forcing him back
and once the bishop moves back another
check on C1
and at this point we switch from trying
to win the Knight to trying to win the
king the king is now under a checkmating
attack just look at how White's pieces
have gathered even the Knight can
participate in the attack and I'll leave
it up to you to finish this off but it's
already totally totally winning it's
plus seven
so this is just one of many important
lines here the only other line that I'll
give for now
is E5 right black can try to prevent the
white Bishop from moving out to F4 the
thing is E5 leaves this diagonal open
and we immediately exploit it and again
the king just cannot make its way to B8
and here I think F4 is best undermining
the pawn then bringing the bishop out
and on the next move we just play King
to D2
and the Knight on A1 is lost but more
importantly after Bishop E7 another
beautiful detail
can anybody spot White's best move in
this position and it's obviously it's
not to take the Knight because then
black is finally out of the woods again
we generate chances against Black's King
all of a sudden
yeah Rook C1
threatening Bishop C5 and preparing
Knight C7 so if black takes check
then we grab
and then we grab on A1 and we win the
game we're up a piece
so that's how you punish E6 and E5
there is a lot more Theory even in this
position but this video is going to go
on forever and something tells me we're
gonna get this again and the whole
philosophy of the speedrun is that I
give you the theory and sort of
bite-sized chunks and ultimately there
will be videos dedicated to Theory so
it's not like you know we'll never
revisit this again but as I always say
you're more than welcome to set this up
on hs.com leeches engine whatever uh and
and just analyze on your own look up the
games and you can learn a lot that way
you don't just have to rely on what I
tell you I'm trying to give you the main
stuff but you can carry the analysis
forward on your own
in any case after a knight to B5 black
can also take on B5 but the king here is
under just tremendous fire The Rook is
coming to D1 and Black's lack of
development absolutely kills him so for
instance here here then we bring the
bishop out and it's literally made in
three because Rook C1 is Unstoppable and
this is also bowden's mate
so
plenty of lines like this I think the
best move for black is to drop back to
E6 and now we play quick F4 F5
and the line goes on but we will revisit
this at a later point
in the game our opponent did none of
that and essentially gave us exactly
what we wanted right away Rook Queen A5
D5
and I already think that black is is
just in huge huge trouble
I don't know what black should do if
black plays Knight E5 then we give this
check on B5 to essentially Force the
Knight out of E5 and this is just
crushing
again good position to sort of dig
around in on your own remember that Rook
d8 here is very strongly met with Bishop
D2 unpinning the pawn and setting up the
X-ray according to the engine black
actually had to give away the exchange
and this was the only way to somewhat
stay alive although here I think a very
good move for white would be to
essentially Force the queen trade with
with Queen to B3
and in the resulting end game white is
not up that much material it's in
exchange for a pawn but if you look at
the queen side pawns they can be
targeted with Bishop B5 black is just
way too underdeveloped here this is just
totally crushing
in any case
this is all very very depressing for
black very sad same with long Castle we
can play Bishop to D2 and it's all the
same stuff right I mean the queen is is
under pressure the Knight is hanging and
if black plays Knight E5 then we could
just go after Black's king with a move
like Knight B5 and the game is over the
queen is hanging
takes takes hits the bishop
simultaneously and if the queen moves
then we can use the compromised position
of Black's King to unpin Our Queen with
check and then grab the Knight and win
the game straight forward this is all
very very simple lines I mean because
black is just black has no pieces in the
game so our opponent took the Knight we
decided to take back with a queen
although as I had mentioned GF is also
worth exploring
um
95 and I actually really like our move
Queen G3 just keeping the queen out of
the range of Black's minor Pieces Just
to reiterate why didn't I go here right
why didn't I play a Tempo well I did
play a Tempo move but it's because the
move G6 here which is the only way for
black to deploy the bishop now comes
with Tempo and this line which I was
attracted to initially isn't as
effective as I thought it was I thought
maybe D6 uh is is interesting it's a
sexy move but I don't think it's I don't
think it's as good as it looks obviously
the idea is to to take the Knight and
win black screen
but
Black's Queen can move
and this is what you have to be so
careful about right because you have to
make sure you're not actually helping
black get their pieces out here suddenly
black clusters around in the center
and is maybe even able to trade Queens
on the next move with Queen E6 so you've
cashed in your chips too early and this
is a good example of one move it is
right playing for one move threats
rather than for the larger attack which
is what you have to try to do in these
positions
okay so instead
we decided on a more measured approach
Queen to G3
I have some questions
if the Knight had gone to D4 instead of
E5
asks wind waiver
and you had gone Queen E4 was there
Knight B3 ooh this is a great question
because Knight B3 is a cool trick right
the queen x-rays The Rook so yes there
would be Knight B3 but I think the
simplest way to win this with white
would probably actually be
to take the Knight
and sacrifice The Exchange and then
deliver a check and then castle kingside
and you should just sense intuitively
the black is dead here because the king
is just toast
um it's not that the queen gets trapped
the queen can move out of the way but
now we go D6 and open up an attack on B7
and the king is surrounded totally
surrounded 800 different ways
this is a position that you should sense
right you should really feel why this is
totally lost and perhaps Knight F6 is
more resilient but now the engine
suggests uh to go to B4 in order to cut
off the only Escape Square available to
Black's Queen this is nothing to be
afraid of because the pawn pushes
forward intercepting the bishop then we
bring our Bishop out and trap the queen
and we also it's just Checkmate a
hundred different ways
so I can you know expand on this but
likely we would have just taken B3 and
you know developed our pieces in
Checkmate to the king
but a great a great find that that would
be a cool defensive idea okay so Knight
D7 Bishop D2
um Knight F6 Bishop D3 again we're
playing simple slow straight forward
chess refraining from automatic moves
this was a great find by our opponent a
very ingenious defensive resource and a
lot of people would have fallen for this
the way to avoid falling for this is
just to double check right we played
Bishop D2 in order to threaten Knight B5
and even though this move doesn't look
like it defends you always have to give
your opponent the benefit of the doubt
and you have to say well let me look a
little bit more deeply and make sure
that this 1700 and Miss in fact missed a
you know an obvious one move threat
sometimes it's actually too good to be
true but you shouldn't trust your
opponent out of hand right you should
play the move if you don't see anything
against it but you shouldn't play it too
quickly there's a balance
in any case we went Bishop D3
we canceled all of our moves were just
incredibly simple G6 and Bishop B3 I
think is the cherry on top obviously
this hastens Black's defeat because
after this we can stop our analysis the
game is over we win a piece or The Rook
um more resilient would have been to
move the queen where could black have
moved it well black could have taken B2
but this position looks totally lost to
me
um because the Knight can actually now
go to B5 threatening Knight C7 and
protecting the bishop and attacking the
queen I mean that's a discovered attack
probably I would have played with black
the move Queen to d8
and the game is not over like if you
look at the engine it's actually black
is able I think to force his way to
castling
but an interesting approach here one
that I
uh had envisioned during the game would
be to play a move like Knight to E4
and in the event of the trade now we can
finally play the move D6 and essentially
we're Shifting the focus of the attack
from the King which we're also attacking
to the B7 Pawn we're cashing in our
chips and yes black and Castle
congratulations but after Bishop takes
B7 we can win the game for instance with
d e and then the simple Bishop F4
opening up a double attack on the queen
and the Rook blackest Castle the king is
safe but he loses material and this is a
more advanced attacking concept that
we'll explore in future videos more more
carefully but we didn't need to use it
here the idea that there's a focus of
the attack and usually it's to mate the
king but you have to be flexible right
sometimes
you have to allow your opponent let's
say to escape but only at the cost of a
decisive amount of material winning
material can be a successful outcome of
an attack as it is here right so it's
not just Checkmate that wins the game it
can also just be winning all of your
opponent's pieces that's why I think
Knight E4 is such a strong move Bishop
G7 by the way there is a check on D6
and Bishop B6 wins the queen so
looks like King f8 was the most
resilient but now we grab another pawn
and white should be able to convert this
uh pretty straightforwardly so you can
continue to you know educate yourself on
these lines Queen D6 I was planning
Bishop F4 ultimately our opponent was
unable to withstand the pressure and uh
missed Bishop D4 after which the rest I
leave sort of up to you we made some
nice moves
um to convert efficiently but everything
I did subsequently is very very
straightforward just remember the
concept of pushing a pawn and then
creating the square that the pawn
vacated for the night as we did here
pushing the pawn and then creating the
square for the night it's also a
positional concept that you see pretty
often there's a lot more stuff I could
talk about but it's you know for those
watching on YouTube it's almost four
that a long day so I'm gonna call it
here hopefully you found the analysis
sufficiently
Illuminating
um again a lot more I can always say but
at some point you got to draw the line
and I'm gonna I'm gonna head to bed so
hope everyone enjoyed the game and the
analysis this was pretty opening heavy
but once we
once we play D5 I mean I would say that
practically speaking the game ended it
didn't end here but the position was
unsalvageable from a human perspective
on move eight which again demonstrates
the power of knowing your openings right
you just make chess a much more fun game
and even if you mess up subsequently
messing up in a winning position is
different from messing up in an equal
position you're still increasing the
likelihood that you're going to win more
games and openings are crucial they make
chess more fun and uh they make you a
nightmare to deal with and the yellow
pen is a total nightmare to deal with as
we display it again in this game thanks
everybody
I'm gonna call it a night
and I'll see you tomorrow thanks
everybody bye
[Music]